KENNY NING: So before
we get started,
let's introduce ourselves.
My name is Kenny.
I've been working at Spotify
for about a year and a half now.
I'm on the Analytics
Departments,
and I work on this team
called Analytics Consulting.
Essentially, what
that means is we have
two departments at Spotify.
There's an analytics team
and there's a content team.
The content team is responsible
for getting the music
on the service, et cetera.
And I function as the interface
between the analytics team
and that content
part of the business.
EMILY SAMUELS: And I'm Emily.
I'm a Data Engineer
at Spotify, and I
work on music recommendations.
My team does things
like discover
weekly, related artists, and
playlist recommendations.
KENNY NING: Cool.
All right.
So before we get started
talking about BigQuery,
maybe it makes sense
to give some context
around where we've come actually
from a data infrastructure
perspective at Spotify.
So ever since the
beginning of Spotify,
we've always managed our own
on-premise Hadoop cluster.
This is where it's great for
us over the past few years.
And even most recently, we're
kind of famous in that we're
the largest.
We have the largest
Hadoop cluster in Europe.
We have about 2,300 nodes.
And we run about
11,000 jobs a day.
So a lot of work
being done there.
And historically, this
is kind of the model
with which we've been able to
get data out of our cluster.
More recently, we've been
experimenting with technologies
like Scalding and Crunch for
our [INAUDIBLE] production jobs.
But in the past, we still have
a lot of jobs actually still
in production that are still
functioning off of the old
out-of-the-box Python MapReduce.
That's for stuff that's
scheduled most of the time.
If we want to do any kind of
ad hoc analysis on our data,
we typically-- our
analysts will use
Hive, which is a SQL
language essentially,
for the more one-off ad hoc
kind of analysis pieces.
So yeah, we were doing
this for a while.
But the problem with
this model is it really--
there's two main
problems, actually,
that were becoming a little
bit more than just problems.
So the first thing, obviously
as you know, all of these things
are MapReduce.
And if you haven't
used MapReduce before,
it scales great.
But the speed of iteration is
actually just incredibly slow.
You're writing a query that
will take you a few minutes.
Sometimes, hours, depending
on how complicated it is.
And this speed was just
becoming a huge problem.
Specifically, I'm
thinking maybe it's
difficult-- it becomes difficult
to report on time-sensitive
asks.
And when I say "time-sensitive,"
imagine a scenario where Taylor
Swift-- you get an email from
your boss and it tells you that
Taylor Swift's taking
her music off Spotify.
You're like, OK,
this is terrible.
I know.
But you need to come back
with metrics within the hour
telling your boss, like how
many playlists she's on.
[? You have to get to PR ?]
quick, right?
But we can't actually do this
in a really reasonable way
to report on these
mission-critical pieces
because the query
takes like an hour.
So sure, you could
argue that this is just
a one-off kind of thing.
But as Spotify becomes more
and more in the public eye,
it's becoming more
and more intolerable
if we're slow to report on
these very mission-critical
time-sensitive pieces.
So that was becoming
a big problem.
Next.
So analytics, we don't just
fight fires all the time.
And I don't think analytics
organizations necessarily
want to do that and spend
their time doing that.
Ideally, you want to
evolve as an organization
to spend most of your time doing
complex, less obvious answers,
and doing kind of
research things.
However, the problem with us--
the main blocker for analytics
to actually evolve into
this good data science
organization, the
main blocker there
was just the speed
of our technologies
that we were using.
You can imagine, sure,
we gave this Taylor Swift
a playlist number, but now your
stakeholder wants to come back
and say, I want to understand
something about the users.
Can we look at the
listeners of Taylor Swift
before the take-down?
Can we look at them after?
Can we come up with some
story that something bad
happened with those users?
So this analysis,
as you know, there's
tons of things you can look at.
And it's really unclear
exactly what numbers
you want to pull at first.
Ideally, you want
an environment that
allows you to iterate quickly
and try a bunch of-- test
a bunch of your
early hypotheses.
Maybe we look at
their churn rates.
Maybe we look at how they're
engaging with other replacement
artists.
You want to test
all of these things.
The problem is you're
using this technology where
every single query costs
you an hour of your time.
And you have to really
think carefully.
And you really don't
have the freedom
to explore as much
as you'd like to.
And that just really
hampers your ability
to do these multi-step
exploratory analyses.
So those were suffering a
lot also from the technology.
Lastly, I'm sure
everyone whose analysis
dealt with this
before, but we'd run
into a really frustrating
situation where you'd kick off
something that was running for
several minutes, several hours,
et cetera.
95% of the way
complete and it just
fails at some single point
in the step of the job.
Hitting a data set that
doesn't exist anymore
or some weird schema
changed or something.
So those, in addition
to just being
common and really
frustrating to an analyst,
they also cost the system a lot
of resources that we couldn't
get back a lot of times.
And this was a
headache for-- we're
owning everything on-premise
and these data infrastructure
engineers have to debug where
these failures are happening.
Especially, the case may be you
have this really bad job that's
just cronned.
You're not really focusing
on it and it's just
taking all these resources
that you can never get back.
And sure, there existed tooling.
We could write unitests.
We could do things to help
prevent these problems,
but it wasn't at a state
where it was entirely usable.
And you know, these
failures kept happening.
So that's on the speed side.
The other main piece
that was a huge problem
with using this on-premise
Hadoop cluster was we
needed to maintain a significant
amount of tooling to actually
make it usable.
So especially not
everyone doing analysis
has a computer science degree
or can write a Scalding job.
Most of them, their skill set
is more in line with statistics
and they know SQL at
best, a lot of cases.
So you can't really
expect an analyst
to be able to SSH
into an edge node
and actually write
this job, kick it off.
So we have to build things
like internal web UIs that
would allow analysts to
just go to a website,
write their own SQL
query, execute something.
But then, this is a product.
And now we're in
a situation where
in addition to all the normal
data infrastructure things
we have to manage, we're
actually creating products now
for internal use that have
all the problems and overhead
and resource constraints
that come with a product.
We have these web UIs
that we have to maintain.
And we have to continue
logging and monitoring
the usage of this, as well
as the machines that we're
provisioning.
There's other harder problems.
If you write a
query in this web UI
and you want to get
millions of rows back,
how do we actually send
that back to the end user?
So all this stuff is
largely, you could imagine,
a fixed responsibility
if we want
to use this on-premise cluster.
And we're investing really
talented, hardworking
engineers, maintaining
all this stuff
that maybe we don't
actually need.
So we need a platform, really,
to solve these problems.
And BigQuery very
early on actually
jumped out as a really
great solution, particularly
number one, to address these two
problems of speed and tooling.
One, it was just
incredibly fast.
I remember still,
actually, there's
like a really small
group of analysts
who were given first access at
Spotify to give the tool a try
and it was just like awesome.
Being able to see getting
used to querying this one data
set that would take you--
being used to waiting 15,
20 minutes for this to run.
And then, suddenly
getting results
back through BigQuery
within 10 seconds.
That was just amazing to
me and super-inspiring.
And really, got me excited
about all the new analyses
that I could do.
It's still in SQL, so
there's no learning curve
for an old analyst
on the old model.
They could jump
right into the tool
and get started immediately.
And again, more
importantly, back
to the piece of the
maintenance piece,
there's just no more
infrastructure to manage.
We were spending
all these engineers
maintaining this stuff.
Now, they were
essentially freed up
with-- if we decide to go with
BigQuery, they were freed up
and we could use them on
more important projects.
So we gave it a try and
here's an example of kind
of how it was implemented.
From an access
perspective, it's also
really easy-- it was
really easy for us
to just get started
and using-- just
get started using the tool.
So we use permissions and access
all done through Google Groups.
Really simple.
And kind of the workflow now as
you enter-- you could imagine
if you're starting as an
analyst, you enter this group
and you get this one project
for free called Data Commons.
So right now, we basically
just have this big project
that has a bunch of
our core data sets
that have-- these data
sets are owned by teams.
You know what's in them.
You can trust the data.
They're like very core to
doing any kind of analysis
at Spotify.
So you get that for free.
And then we're also
organizing projects
according to specific teams.
So you could imagine
a team that's
working on a running
feature could have
their own project called
Running that gives them,
in addition to their own
sort of little sandbox
that would allow them to upload
whatever ad hoc data sets they
want to look at just
for analysis purposes,
ad hoc debugging purposes.
They could have the
freedom to do that
without mucking up and ruining
the experience of Data Commons
for the larger analysis
at Spotify community.
And as far as actually
getting the data,
this is kind of
what it looks like.
We still have a lot of
our jobs writing to HDFS.
So pretty regularly,
we have a pipeline
that's pushing stuff
from HDFS into GCS.
From there, that's where
BigQuery is calling from.
And most use cases, we just use
the out-of-the-box web UI that
comes with BigQuery.
That's like really
easy to use, really
easy to get started with.
That probably solves 90% of
the use cases of our analysts
who just want to write a
SQL query, hit a button,
and get results back.
Really easy to do that.
However, there's
also this use case.
We use Jupiter a lot within
the analytics community.
If you've ever used
IPython Notebook,
it's basically the
iteration of that.
A nice, little place
that allows you
to share work and marry your
code with actual result sets.
So yes.
So we actually wrote a
few plugins within Jupiter
that would allow us to directly
query from our BigQuery data
sets within this environment
that we were used to.
Sure.
We could have used a tool
like Google Datalab, which
we saw earlier, actually
today, as like an alternative
to a notebooking environment
as an alternate to Jupiter.
But at the time, we
were already so used
to-- it was nice that we didn't
have to sacrifice our existing
environment and our existing
familiarity with Jupiter.
And we could very
easily, actually,
like flexibly still
adapt that environment
into this new data model.
So yes, Datalab
would have been--
I think could be a
solution as well.
But at the time, we
were using Jupiter.
We decided to go
down this route.
And it was OK as well.
So now the data is all
there and it's implemented,
but then the next piece was
how are you actually going
to get people at Spotify
to actually go out and use
all this work that
has been already done?
So from this business
onboarding perspective,
the way we solved
this problem, was just
a lot of workshops, in-person
workshops on BigQuery.
So they started with whole-day
on-sites with Google New York.
We had some of the BigQuery
team come to our office
and sit with this early pilot
group of 10 or so analysts,
go over sort of the
guts of how it worked.
They were even nice
enough to sit down with us
and actually debug
some of the queries
and answer very specific
questions that we were having.
After that, a lot of us
in this early test group
went out to the
rest of the company
and the rest of the
analysis community
and shared a lot
of our learnings
directly in sort of informal
workshops with coworkers.
This was, I thought, crucial
to actually getting--
you can imagine, there's a
lot of old-school analysts
who are just used to Hive and
that's just what they know.
And they're not going to
really switch their behavior
unless you actually go
out and talk to them
and show them the
upsides, like here is
an example of what you do now.
Here's why it's
better in BigQuery.
So those were really
essential to getting
some of the older coworkers, or
more veteran coworkers, moved
over to this new platform.
And now it's
actually really great
to see that for
all new employees
today, in the onboarding
process we basically
just start with BigQuery.
And it's been really easy and
a really smooth onboarding
process, specifically because
of the speed piece of it.
Our analysts can really
just get into the tool
and into the web UI
immediately, mess around
with a data set
query, and really get
a very quick familiarity of
what our data looks like.
On a more ongoing basis, we've
done a good job, I think,
of creating a strong
learning culture at Spotify.
We have very active
Slack channels.
That's typically the first
place for a new big query user
to go and ask a question.
If that doesn't
work, we typically
point people to the BigQuery
docs, which are really solid.
If you haven't
looked at them yet,
like huge improvement
over the Hive
docs if you've ever
looked at them before.
It solves basically most of
our questions that we have.
And the Stack Overflow
community also
has been actually pretty
responsive as well.
So maybe to give it a
little bit more color,
here's some examples of
real-life, you could imagine,
recurring business data requests
that Spotify faces with.
And here are some numbers to
show you the 35x and more--
like basically, improvement
in efficiency that BigQuery
has given to us.
So I'm just going to
give you an example.
So you can imagine, like
somebody wants to get KPIs
by specified parameters.
Some marketing person wants
to know the MAU of Spotify
in Brazil among 18
to 24-year-olds.
So this is an ad hoc query.
It requires an analyst to
write something and pull data.
In the Hive scenario,
you'd write this.
You'd maybe leave, go do
something else, come back.
In the new world with
BigQuery, you can write this
and you get results
basically immediately.
And it's over.
And basically, this is
a huge upside as well.
Because you could imagine you'd
want to pull KPIs very often.
So this could be a very
daily recurring request
that we can do
now in 10 seconds.
Maybe the same marketer wants
to go out and be like, OK.
I want to do this
social targeting
campaign in Australia.
Give me all the super-fans
of Foo Fighters or something.
And I want to give
them an email,
like here's this concert.
And do this targeting thing.
I want some emails.
Well, when they normally ask
analysts for that-- again,
this is very specific.
You'd have to write
some Hive job for it.
It'd take a long time.
Now that we have all
this speed with BigQuery,
we can do more and more of
these really targeted campaigns.
Lastly, like top tracks.
Top tracks we refer to
internally as kind of our--
it's our word
count, essentially,
problem at Spotify.
It's like the bread and
butter analysis question.
So you can imagine a
label person comes to you
and wants to know the top
tracks of Justin Bieber
among 55-year-olds.
This is the only job, by the
way, where that's not weird.
You pull this all the time and
no one even asks you twice.
You're just like, that's my job.
I pull Justin Bieber
tracks, I guess.
But yeah, like Hive, that
takes essentially a day.
And now with BigQuery, you
can deliver on these reports,
again, instantaneously and
just save yourself so much time
going forward.
So these largely, again, are
examples of more recurring,
like day-to-day
business wins that we've
gotten from BigQuery.
I'm going to head
it over to Emily now
and she's going to go over
two really powerful examples
of longer-term projects that
we were really able to leverage
the platform of BigQuery and
get really great efficiency
upsides.
So take it, Emily.
[APPLAUSE]
EMILY SAMUELS: Thanks, Kenny.
Because of the ease
of use and the speed
that we've gained
with BigQuery, we
were able to solve two problems
that we were facing at Spotify.
One is around what we
call Audience Insights.
And this is looking at
how users are actually
interacting with our service.
And the other one is around
evaluating A/B tests.
But first, I'll go
over Audience Insights.
We have a lot of teams at
our company, like marketing,
and growth, and ad sales.
And they have a lot
of questions about,
what our users doing
on our service?
They ask things like,
how many free users
between the age of 18 and 30
listen to hip hop in the US?
What platforms do these
hip hop fans like to use?
And how do these platform
habits differ from all free 18
to 30-year-olds in the US?
Before using Hive
in our old system,
getting this information and
answering these questions,
it was a really manual process.
It involved a lot of time
on the analyst's end,
just pulling the data together
and writing these jobs.
And then, the
analysts would spend
a lot of time waiting
for Hive to complete.
So it took a lot of time
to answer these questions.
The information was
scattered around our system.
You might need to be an expert
on where to find information
about our users,
where is it stored,
or know somebody
who is an expert.
So it's hard just to gather
all the information together.
And finally, we had a
lot a Band-Aid solutions.
We had analysts who
would put together
dashboards with no
clear SLA, and then they
would leave the company.
So it was unclear whether we
could rely on these dashboards
anymore or how to update them.
We also tried using some
third-party solutions.
But this, again, involved a
lot of manual intervention
on the analyst's
part because they'd
have to gather up all
this data and send it over
to the third party to process.
And then, in the
end we'd wind up
having the numbers from
the third-party dashboards
and the numbers in
our own dashboards.
They weren't in agreement.
So it was just kind of a mess.
So we decided once
we got BigQuery,
we could build this web app that
we called Audience Insights.
And I'll go over how it works.
So it's a web page that
people can go to and choose
a bunch of different parameters,
like whether they want
to look at people in the US
or in other countries, what
ages they want to look at, just
different demographic features.
Once they've chosen all of those
filters, a request gets made.
If we've already answered
that request before,
it's in our cache and we
return the answer quickly.
So this just increases--
or this makes
the requests a lot faster.
But if it's not in our cache,
we have this Python API
that turns that request into
up to 15 different queries that
run on top of BigQuery.
Initially, because
we were running
so many queries at once, getting
the results was kind of slow.
But we decided to have
dedicated computing slots
to field all of these
queries and that
improved the turnaround time.
And I'll show you
what this looks
like with some mocked up data.
Here's one graph where you can
see users by age and gender.
So you can just see
this break down.
There's also streams by genre.
So if you want to look at, what
are the top genres that people
are streaming, you can see here
that pop and metal are our most
popular genres on Spotify.
And finally, if you want to dig
even deeper, you can look at,
how are people actually
streaming things in terms of,
are they streaming from
their own collection?
Are they streaming from
their saved playlists?
Are they listening to radio?
Discover weekly?
You can really get a deep dive
into how users are interacting
with our service.
What's great about
this is that now we
can field all of these
different questions from people
and they feel really
empowered because now they
can go to this website
and get the information
themselves rather than
having to go to an analyst
and wait a while and have this
analyst spend a lot of time
answering these questions.
So we freed up a lot of
time for our analysts.
And we've empowered
different teams at Spotify
to answer their own questions.
And now I'll talk about
how we use BigQuery
for evaluating A/B tests.
I have a screenshot here
of the Spotify Home page.
You can see there's a
bunch of different shelves,
like recently played
and popular playlists.
But we want to test different
content to our users.
And we want to see,
are they engaged
with this different content?
What if we showed
different genres or charts?
We want to run a
lot of experiments
and see our users seeing
a lot of our content.
Are they scrolling down?
Are they streaming things?
Once they start streaming,
do they stream for a while?
Before getting the answers
to these questions,
it was a really manual process.
Just like with
Audience Insights,
an analyst would be
involved for every A/B test.
They would have to gather
up all of this data,
run these Hive queries.
It was just really involved.
But once we got BigQuery, we
decided to leverage its speed
and its ease of use to build a
tool for evaluating A/B tests.
We started off using
Scalding to clean up our data
and to join our different
data sets together.
This was just work that really
couldn't be done in BigQuery,
so we decided to
do it in Scalding.
And it's something that
you could do in Dataflow,
but our team was
familiar with Scalding,
so we just kind of
went with that first.
Once we had this cleaned
and joined up data,
we put that into BigQuery.
We experimented with a
bunch of different schemas.
But ultimately, we decided that
the rawest form of the data
would be best.
And because of that, now we can
have these scheduled queries
that run that
aggregate up the data.
And we did this so that
if any of our metrics
change, if we decided we want
to look at something different,
we don't need to actually
change any of the Scalding jobs.
We can just add some
new scheduled queries.
What's also really great about
having our data in BigQuery
is that it's easier
to find data issues.
Sometimes, things come up.
There's a logging issue,
data just looks weird.
And now instead of having
to write Scalding jobs
or look in data in HDFS, we can
really quickly run some queries
and see where things
are going wrong.
So it's been great for
us for debugging as well.
Now that we had this
data in BigQuery
and we have our metrics, we used
Tableau to actually visualize
our A/B testing results.
And what's been great about this
is we have these dashboards now
where if you run an A/B test,
we have this visualization
that you just get for free.
And any new test just
automatically flow through here
because it's
connected to BigQuery.
And it's really
empowered our teams
to run their own A/B
tests, and get the results,
and make decisions
without having to have
an analyst involved every time.
So again, just like
with Audience Insights,
we've really empowered teams
to iterate fast and answer
their own questions.
And now I'll switch
over to the demo.
So this is a Tableau dashboard
that one of our analysts
have set up around evaluating
A/B tests for the Home page.
So let's say, for
example, we made
a test around the
recently played strip
that I showed you guys.
And we want to look
at how it's doing.
You could pick
different tests here.
There's only one for the demo.
Again, this is all
mocked up data.
You can choose what dates
you want to look at,
and then whether this is a
test for new users or not.
We have a bunch
of different tabs.
Here is an Overview
tab where you
can look at how the different
content is doing in your test.
We have the percentage of total
impressions at the top here.
So this is just, what are
people actually seeing
on the Home page?
And we have the percentage
of total streams, 30 seconds.
So are people actually streaming
things once they see it?
We can see here for recently
played that for the test,
there's 20% of the
total impressions,
but only 15% of the total
streams, 30 seconds.
And for control, there's around
13% of the total impressions
and 14% of the total
streams, 30 seconds.
So just from looking
at this dashboard,
we can see that
something in the test
is causing people not to stream
once they have impressions.
We also have this conversion map
where we have different metrics
on the x-axis and the y-axis.
On the x-axis, we have
impression-to-stream
conversions.
So once somebody actually saw
something on the Home page,
did they actually listen to it?
And on the y-axis, we have
streams-to-long session
conversions.
Once somebody actually
streams something,
did they listen for a while?
And you can see here
the different bubbles.
We have them broken out by
this different content types.
And any bubbles that are in
the top right, that means they
have the highest engagement.
So we can look here at different
content types, like editorial.
You can see the test is
more engaging than control.
And for recently played, you can
see that control is a lot more
engaging than the test.
And if you want, you can only
look at certain things in here.
You can look by different
types of content.
So for example,
I chose URI type.
This is looking at things like,
are users listening to radio?
Are they listening to charts?
Are they listening to albums?
Which types of content
are more engaging?
And here's a deeper dive
into those URI types.
You can see here we have
three different metrics.
There's impression-to-long
sessions,
impression-to-stream
conversions,
and streams-to-long
session conversions.
You can see here if
you looked at recently
played how the different
URI types are performing.
You can look at radio and
see that for the control,
radio is much more engaging
on all metrics than the test.
But for something like
charts, there's really not
much of a difference.
This is just another way
of slicing up the data.
We have average streams.
And we have it broken out
by different content types.
So we have recently played,
popular, and editorial.
And right now, we're
looking at this broken up
by registration date.
So when users signed
up to our service,
how engaged are they with
this different content?
We can break it up by
gender, by financial product.
So whether people are
free or premium users.
You can see the
breakdown by country.
And also by age group.
So you get a really
good view into how
your test is performing, and
can really do a deep dive
and slice deeply into this data.
And then finally at
the end, you need
to decide whether you
want to roll out this test
or to roll it back.
So we have this
decision-making chart.
You could see the different
content types and how
they're performing overall.
And these are statistically
significant results.
You could see here
that for editorial,
the control and the
test-- it's hard to tell.
There's not really
much difference
of how it's performing.
For personalized,
it's pretty obvious
that the test is performing
better than control.
But for popular and
recently played,
the tests are performing poorly.
And this is for stream-to-long
session conversions.
We can look at
impressions-to-stream
conversions and
see the same thing.
If we want to look
at the test overall,
you can see that the test
is performing a lot worse
than the control.
So we probably don't
want to roll this out.
And now I'll switch
back to the slides.
So again, this has been
a tool that has really
empowered people at our
company to run A/B tests
and really to iterate fast.
And it's just given them
a way to make decisions
about their own A/B tests
without involving an analyst
for every single one.
And now I'll turn it
back over to Kenny.
KENNY NING: Great.
Thanks, Emily.
[APPLAUSE]
Am I on?
Yeah.
So I hope this has been great.
This has been
informative in the kinds
of like real-world
business problems
that we've been able
to solve with BigQuery.
To recap, in addition to sort
of the recurring daily data
delivery kind of
stuff that analysts
are responsible
for delivering on,
and in addition
to just improving
the efficiency of those queries
across the board like Emily
basically showed us,
the speed with which
we were able to
operate with BigQuery,
essentially like
fundamentally changed
how the company actually
thought about A/B tests.
And how they looked
at the results
after launching A/B tests,
which is just huge for us.
And it wouldn't have been
possible without the upsides
that BigQuery was
able to provide.
So judging from all this stuff,
we're really excited about it
clearly, personally.
But you know,
BigQuery specifically
is maybe not as mainstream at
Spotify as we'd want it to be.
So as far as next
steps, we're still
continuing to spread adoption
of BigQuery across the company,
especially as we're
hiring more people.
Initially, as you
saw, for example,
when Emily was talking about A/B
tests, the Scalding piece that
had to occur before we
actually built this Tableau
dashboard, maybe as
a next step we also
want to investigate other
tools within the GCP suite.
Maybe Dataflow is a
better fit in that piece
and can replace Scalding.
I also talked about earlier how
we actually still use Jupiter
as our notebook environment.
Maybe we want to invest more
time looking into Datalab.
And even Data Studio,
which we saw today,
which was really awesome,
as potential next steps
for our environments.
Audience Insights,
it's worth mentioning
that it's the very
first app at Spotify
that we built on top
of this new platform.
It's been hugely
successful already
and we're going to want to
continue to make more apps,
like Audience Insights.
Again, just so we can
continue to empower people
with data who are not
necessarily technically-- who
are not analysts.
And free up time
for our analysts
as well to do more
exploratory analyses.
Lastly, it's just
worth mentioning
Spotify is actually--
on the company level,
we're taking on this new
mission called Data-First, which
is becoming a top company bet.
What that means is that
the whole company is caring
about this concept
of defining, what
does it mean to be a Data-First
company in today's day and age?
What kind of sub-projects can
we do to achieve this mission?
So here's kind of a taste
of what this top company
bet looks like for Spotify and
what our future looks like.
You could imagine we
have a team working
on defining our key
metrics for the company.
You know, these are
the metrics that
allow us to assess the
health and allow our board
and our lead team to assess
the health of our business.
And you know, this team
would theoretically
come up with those metrics
and also standardize
the way with which
new functional leaders
or new project leaders want
to select baskets of metrics
to evaluate the work.
So we want to go ahead
and standardize and just
add more rigor to that process.
We're doing things like
the reexamining how
we organize and store our data.
As we move into this
new cloud partnership,
maybe it's a really
good time for us
to actually sit down
and actually rethink,
is our data model still working?
Does it still make sense today
as it did several years ago
when we first came up with it?
We're also doing
things like launching
this program called Data
University internally
at Spotify.
This is a well-thought
out curriculum
that we largely internally
brainstormed and thought up
end-to-end that's several weeks
long, intended for engineers
who want to get more interested
into the data-- basically,
get more interested
within big data.
So the goal of this
kind of program
is just to level up the
quality of data engineering
at the company among all of
our engineering community.
And depending on how
successful that goes,
we might even consider open
sourcing this and really
officially becoming a
thought leader in this area.
So to just wrap it up.
If all of these early successes
and all of these early wins
are any indication
of working with-- are
an early indication
of working with GCP,
we're just increasingly more
confident and more inspired
that Spotify is going to
continue to become a top data
company within our industry.
So thank you again for coming.
[APPLAUSE]